[Música]
y momento de pasar a conversar con
nuestra primera invitada del día hoy
abordamos el nuevo acuerdo migratorio de
la Unión Europea una pacto alcanzado la
semana pasada por los ministros de
interior del bloque comunitario la
renovación del marco legal implicaría
cuotas de distribución de los
demandantes de asilo establecidas en
función del pib y de la población de
cada país europeo y en caso de
incumplimiento de estas cuotas los
estados deberán pagar una multa de
20.000 euros por persona no recibida
además el acuerdo facilita también las
expulsiones hacia terceros países Aunque
estos no sean el territorio de origen de
la persona deportada conectamos ahora
con Ruth Ferrero ella es docente de
ciencia política y estudios europeos en
la universidad complutense de Madrid
Además investigadora del instituto de
estudios internacionales Ruth Muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros en France
24 Le agradezco mucho que esté aquí
ayudándonos a entender esta cuestión que
miramos desde América Latina por eso le
pregunto y le pido una breve síntesis
sobre en qué supone un cambio este nuevo
pacto de política migratoria respecto a
lo que había vigente hasta ahora
Bueno realmente no hay cambios
sustantivos en este en esta primer
avance no y después está en marcha del
pacto de migración y asilo de hace un
par de años y lo que se sí que se ha
conseguido llegar es a esa cuota de
solidaridad que se llama cuota de
solidaridad obligatoria pero flexible es
decir ni que los estados miembros se
corresponsabilicen en el acogida en la
acogida a las personas que lleguen
al territorio de la Unión Europea y que
pueden elegir bien pagar por no pagar
por no por no acogerlas O acogerlas y
dotar a sus servicios de integración y
primera acogida a esas personas en
realidad lo que estamos observando
lo que estamos observando es
la concreción de un punto que ya estaba
previsto en el en el pacto de migración
y asilo y sé lo que se hace es concretar
efectivamente Cuál va a ser precio entre
comillas por persona migrante que no
quiera será que no vaya a ser acogida
Por alguno de los países en en este en
este marco Claro porque previamente con
Los acuerdos que se llamaron de dublín
por la ciudad donde se firmaron el marco
en la Unión Europea era que los países
donde un demandante de asilo llegara por
primera vez debía hacerse cargo de estas
solicitudes no lo que digamos cargaba
con mayor peso administrativo a los
países fronterizos sobre todo en las
costas del Mediterráneo como sería en
España Italia o Grecia En qué cambia
este marco esta situación
Bueno una cosa es el desarrollo del
pacto de migración y asilo y otras la
reforma de la seca que es precisamente
la reforma del marco del marco del
asidero de los y de los acuerdos de
dublín Yo creo que el que todavía no
estamos en el punto de la Reforma
global y holística del
de las políticas de asilo en el marco de
la Unión Europea porque no hay una
reforma normativa ilegal precisamente de
eso porque no hay acuerdo en el marco de
los de los reglamentos de los
reglamentos de dublín teníamos que
reformar esos reglamentos de dublín y
llevan bloqueados ya demasiados años
desde el año 2016 están bloqueados lo
que sí que estamos viendo Es esa
propuesta de pacto de migración y así lo
que en realidad no es un pacto porque es
una propuesta de la comisión pero la
comisión lo vende a la opinión pública
como un pacto entre Estados en el cual
está centrado fundamentalmente en
el control y la gestión de las fronteras
no entran otras cuestiones como podría
ser la la forma legislativa
del asilo no de los reglamentos de
dublín que es a lo que usted se a lo que
usted se refería lo que estamos viendo
Es cómo se están poniendo de acuerdo
cómo se quieren poner de acuerdo los
distintos estados miembros
o poner en marcha esos principios de
solidaridad precisamente por lo que
usted apuntaba porque en momentos de
crisis humanitarias como las que hemos
vivido en el marco europeo en el año
2015-2016 o como se han vivido en otros
en otros lugares como puede ser en la
frontera No si nos salimos del
continente de la frontera en la frontera
norteamericana y mexicana Bueno pues en
el caso de la Unión Europea lo que de lo
que se trata es de compartir la gestión
fronteriza y por tanto también las
cargas de la gestión fronteriza Y esto
es algo que a muchos estados miembros
les cuesta entender les cuesta entender
que las fronteras son comunes y
precisamente eso es parte de eso es
parte del mercado único no
el control de las fronteras ha de ser
compartido también y
genera problemas tanto para los países
que están en la frontera exterior como
puede ser el caso España
porque no quiere Obviamente que que
nadie venga a controlar sus fronteras
pero al mismo tiempo quiere que la
solidaridad de la recepción se comparta
con los países que están en el centro y
el norte y el norte europeo porque como
vimos ya digo en el año en el año 15 16
Grecia Italia soportaron una importante
presión humanitaria por la cantidad de
personas que estaban llegando en un
corto periodo de tiempo en las cuales la
gestión del asilo no era no era posible
hacerla de manera adecuada y ahora bien
si me disculpe que no tenemos mucho
tiempo precisamente le quería pedir
profundizar en algo que usted comentaba
y es en ese control de fronteras las
fronteras del Mediterráneo de la Unión
Europea son las más mortíferas del mundo
le pregunto qué se hace para evitar esta
mortalidad en las fronteras europeas
bueno buena pregunta
pues no se hace demasiado realmente
porque lo que lo que los mecanismos los
instrumentos que ya existen en el marco
de la Unión Europea que podrían evitar
esas muertes son por ejemplo la
concesión de asilos humanitarios en los
lugares de origen por ejemplo no o
conceder el asilo en embajadas y
consulados de la Unión Europea bueno
Pues básicamente no está permitido en el
marco en el marco de la unión por tanto
hasta que no pisan territorio europeo
estas personas no pueden ejercer ese
derecho ese derecho al asilo pero
Permítame que incida en uno de las
cuestiones que yo creo que son
fundamentales y que es tan terrible en
el caso en el caso de la Unión Europea
lo que se ha negociado lo que se ha
aprobado en estos últimos días
esencialmente lo que plantea es son
expulsiones rápidas y esto atenta
directamente contra el derecho
internacional humanitario y sobre todo
contra el no refulemón que es Es decir
si tú tienes expulsiones rápidas no te
da tiempo estudiar los dos si eres de
las personas que eventualmente pueda
solicitar solicitar el asilo y lo que
hace lo que se ha acordado y lo esencial
de lo que ya he acordado en estos
últimos días es precisamente eso
acelerar los procedimientos de expulsión
por un lado van a ir las personas
procedentes de países a los que seguro
que se les va a dar el asilo o muy
probablemente Como por ejemplo puede ser
Siria o como por ejemplo puede ser
Ucrania pero otros países otras personas
procedentes y otras nacionalidades por
el mero hecho de ser de otras
nacionalidades pueden ser devueltos de
manera rápida no solamente a su país de
origen sino también a un tercer país sí
ruta exactamente y si no me equivoco en
la tribunal europeo de Derechos Humanos
avaló estas prácticas en el caso con un
caso en España Bueno una cuestión muy
muy compleja Muchísimas gracias por
habernos ayudado a entenderla aquí en
France 24
gracias a vosotros nosotros hacemos una
breve pausa y enseguida volvemos
[Música]